it's just not sexy like you don't come
on man yeah but not everything in life
is about being sexy
it is in a relationship though dude
you're comfortable on each other enough
you're there
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
what's up dude how you doing man you're
back daddy i'm back dude
i don't know where theo is nobody does
you never i mean i don't know
i don't know dude it's at the point now
where i'm just ready to go
it's 7 30 in the morning and i'm just
ready to get the text and get over here
yeah
yeah that chrissy spotlight would shoot
up in the sky and you just bounce here
dude
you gotta do it so early because you're
shooting that tv [ __ ] i'm shooting that
true tv show that's where that's why i'm
dressed like a russian gangster
uh russian gangster or an american idol
season
yeah well this looks like you're on
american idol you got dressed by
american idol well here's the thing they
didn't give me
a show uh a wardrobe budget oh
so they i and there's no wardrobe person
so like you have to just bring your own
clothes so i'm wearing lululemon
athleisure pants
and some shirt that i found in a bin in
downtown l.a for 9.99 but you look good
deal because here's the thing i i
appreciate you saying i look good
but i don't feel good that's the worst
and when you know when you're off if you
don't feel good you know you're out here
i feel cute today you
for and you look cute you look cute and
you got a multi-colored button down on
you look good you got the little baby
communion chain what is that a smiley
face that's the thick boy official logo
dickboy official logo right you're
becoming a monster yes um
i think that i think that um i don't
feel good because
last night do you think he's your body
no first of all i've been going to
barry's boot camp
oh i went to barry's boot camp outdoor
uh trainer shout out to trainer one of
the gay guys
um complimented me that i my ass was
high which is
i appreciate that oh like you have a
height he was like you have a high ass
he was like he was like um
i was at double floor station eight so
it's dfa they're like df-8 get that high
ass up in the air i was like ooh yes
um but uh i had i did barry's boot camp
and then and then i had a good day of
eating and then last night
there's this restaurant in la called
dominico's
it's italian food from staten island i'm
familiar with it dude dominico's it's
the best
food the great tim dillon brought it
over to my house the great tim dillon
came to my house two days ago
i looked at him brought over dominico's
at 1pm said
just let this thaw out i'm going to come
back at 6 00 pm we're going to have a
feasting oh
he brought over like what a friend
brought over like 800
worth of food then just just you and him
me feasting
me him and my girl and my kids and my
family was like i was like with the
whole family
on tim dillon tim paid for it he's the
best then just doesn't come back that
night
so then i just have all this food and
then he's like oh i'm gonna come he said
he's gonna come yesterday because he
left his wallet at my house
so i was like okay come get your wallet
and we'll eat some food wallet with id
credit card everything never hear from
him nothing text him this morning i'm
like you're gonna come he's like i'm out
of here buddy back to texas
enjoyed the miracles i'm like what about
your wallet he's like i'll get a new one
without your idea he doesn't care what a
wild man
yeah but i ate last night i ate i ate um
um spinach puccatini
pumpkin ravioli mushroom ravioli chicken
cacciatore
like 10 pounds of sauce then oh my gosh
[ __ ] in his pants yeah then me and my
family wanted to walk it off and we
walked it off all the way to salt and
straw ice cream
where i got salted cookie dough malt ice
cream but i get yes
and now and i woke up today and i'm v
jiggly
you're a little jiggly i am i got tits
today is this a new [ __ ] couch by the
way
it is dude it's kind of like the the
casting couch
it is it's it takes up a lot of space
it's also nick's bed it's one of those
things where if i'm is this him on is
this
is this the hitter on zoom yeah he sent
in actually an intro message now again
the second tier is hidden
so it looks like he's wearing [ __ ]
minimal hitler
mtt minimum what up chris
what up bird cage what are you fellas
doing
huh um i got a surprise for you the
surprise
is
[Music]
no i'm not gonna be coming in the door
um i can't make it over there today
got some bird mites and stuff like that
white kid uh
he's backyard work he bought a house at
some bird mites and stuff like that i'm
dealing with
that outdoor stuff
indoor stuff all types of different
stuff that's um
it's just uh just impossible to get
positive for a second into the studio
this week
theo's the guy you ever seen obviously
you have shawshank redemption you know
the warden
when they're when they're uh tarring the
roof and he's like yeah i found out i
got 50 grand coming to me and everyone's
like oh he goes yeah but then
you know i get that convertible and the
kids are crying and everyone's like
what's 50 grand dude
that's theo he's like yeah i got this
new house in nashville i'm like dude
that's great yeah
but there's a pool i gotta hire a pool
guy yeah and then there's grass i'm like
what is going on right now this is what
happens but also i'm like
red just sipping the the [ __ ] cold
one being like chill out
but where's the oh the house is in
nashville i thought it was in like the
where he's from in louisiana where
no i wouldn't go back to him he's in
nashville oh he lives in a real place
now yes
well la's real place but so he either
you know
it's like people either you know follow
rogan to texas
yeah or they're going to nashville
that's where all our friends that's
where everyone's going
not me baby not me i got it down here
yeah i'm just i'm i'm going back to new
york
i'm going to live in new york they're
like it's a 14.8 percent tax hike i'm
like so what
i'm depressed enough i'll just give all
my money to the government and they just
recall the johnson and johnson vaccine
today because it's giving blood clots
well guess what i'm taking it anyway
yeah i'm just gonna take it anyway and
light me up
what's a blood clot you know birth
control gives you blood clots
flying on planes for a long time gives
you blood flying on planes gives you
bean fat gives you blood clots yeah you
think it's a conspiracy
the johnson johnson because it's only
one shot that's what you said
uh i don't know about that i don't
believe conspiracies oh you don't you're
not
okay yeah yeah okay so i guess we can
say that keep going but
i will be back next week um
chris i want to thank you for holding it
down he looks like he's emotional
um you know i really appreciate it right
brandon
um and yeah i miss you guys man
narc chin uh
um who's like a lead singer of a late
90's
he's
i can't even remember all the people
that work at the studio slowly the
transition
blown punch down and
we just accepted what else not much man
i love you guys and i wish i really do
wish that i was there
i wish i was dead and you look like goat
boy from saturday night
both of you guys we're talking about yes
syndrome you know exactly what do you
say it's funny
all right man you guys did you say
though man he said i wish i was there
ripping both you guys a new [ __ ] and
you know what i'm talking about bronson
that's funny brown's funny brand
syndrome's
he looks like he slowly transitioned
either a goat or full-blown female
yeah it's one of the other theo theo is
uh
but you know what the thing is with theo
is even though
he's one of those guys where he looks
like [ __ ] but he looks also looks great
i know girls that dig him i'm like
you're disgusting yeah he looks great
though like but he also looks like he's
slowly unraveling i don't know
it's it's it looks like a guy at the end
of his life but also the beginning of
his life i can't explain it the theo
slowly transitions to go boy
he doesn't look a little bit like oat
boy he does look a little bit
yeah you want to talk about a conspiracy
now jim brewer shout out jim brewer
he's great though dude i was on the i
was on a cruise uh i did a crew the
impractical joker's cruise with him and
we were sitting out on his balcony deck
just talking about 5g
oh it's like holy [ __ ] yeah jimmy
oh no jimmy b is the best dude i'm
telling you
i did that i did that cruise right
and i watched jim brewer every night go
headline dude he did three different
hours and i'm talking about annihilated
to the
it's one of those things where a guy
like jim brewer is from that class
of snl comedians that you genuinely have
to be
the funniest person one of the top 10
funniest people
in the country to get that show like
he's from
the elite of the elite class so when you
watch those guys
do you stand up there's no like let me
figure this out there's no bringing
notes
he just goes and [ __ ] rips and it was
a very eye-opening thing to watch him i
was like oh wait
this is what like the one percent of
comedians used to look like
this is what these guys are like there's
just it is their life like he could come
in here
anywhere podcast setting stand-up
setting and just annihilate
do you think about it he was uh opening
emceeing for
metallica and arenas in stadiums and
crushing dudes
yeah and you obviously metallic fans
like what the [ __ ] is this
and he's still bringing the house down
it's a different it's a different uh
it's a different energy it's a different
thing when i watched jim brewer it made
me
want to jump off the boat and i should
have jumped off the ball because [ __ ]
covered was gonna happen anyway were you
oh
uh yeah they started i was yeah i was
one of like ten community it was
actually uh
you know people were in convenience
that's too long of a show well i don't
know it was like the impractical jokers
cruise
it was actually in february of 20 of uh
2020 right before the show
before yes there were actually some
coveted cases already in asia and some
cruise ships
that had been like docked where the
people couldn't get off yeah they were
the petri dishes i was very close
i was did you know that there was an
actual comedian on one of those boats
that got stuck
and he jumped off the boat because he
had to go get to another boat in alaska
for a gig oh
what a savage what a savage
and hopefully that show was sold out you
son of a [ __ ] what a beast to do that i
know he did that and
and i remember like that cruz uh it was
actually kind of fun to like
just like be on the the thing is with
the cruise though i was like oh
we're on the open ocean and i spoke to
one of like the first mate
deckhand [ __ ] i don't know what the
hell it is yeah but he was like
we're actually not on the open ocean
he's like we keep just going back and
forth
from miami to the bahamas and we're just
making a big circle
he was like because the people on this
boat just want to see the water yeah
he's like but
he was like let me show you the plan and
they literally just kept making donuts
in the ocean about three miles off the
coast of miami he's like
you're too stupid to pick up on it why
would we waste all the gas to go all the
way to where the [ __ ] yeah yeah he was
like he was like how he's in a circle
i know he said to me he was like haven't
you felt haven't you noticed that we've
been turning i was like yeah i thought
there were icebergs or something
sure you know he's so yeah shout out to
impractical joker's crew shout out jim
brewer
uh you know he's most impractical joker
boys move
tickets wanna talk about tickles yeah
those guys
those guys sell a lot of tickets because
they are they're literally every person
on the planet knows who they are knows
their show i'm talking about
from like three year olds tonight my
five year old yeah my dad
oh yeah but it's like you want to see
funny you need to watch them
like but you know what it is and now now
see here's the thing
now i'm doing the true tv show and true
tv and these networks they just want to
keep remaking
the impractical jokers in any way they
can which is tough to do because those
guys were friends for 30 years
they're both before they had a show
chemistry the chemistry it's like you
know they
you can't just even my show they're like
we're going to make it the impractical
jokers of building i'm like the guys i'm
with
i just met 10 minutes ago but that's
hollywood you know what i'm saying
they're like oh we'll just do this or
we'll do this yeah yeah yeah
no yeah we're all friends dude that's
why this works well now now i know let's
put morgan freeman with you guys be
hilarious i know they've they've
instituted now in my show an element of
a of like a prank surprise they're like
oh
a surprise i'm like what am i going to
surprise them with the 2x4 to the head
yeah this is a build show you build the
[ __ ] bar
and is there anything worse when you
have riders in the room and this is for
that
type of tv show and they write something
that they think is funny oh god
i'm telling you this isn't gonna work no
for my show they'll just shout it out
from like the crowd they'd be like say
this and it's like oh
god but i just to be honest with you i'm
not i'm one of those guys
where i know some people be like no i'm
i'm the funniest guy in the room blah
blah but i just say what they say
and i'm like dude do whatever you want
to get an editing edit me however the
hell yeah i have no control over the
edit so i'm kind of like i've given up
i have i that's that's my attitude
towards my company man now yeah i'm just
well not even that i'm just like i've
given up so
when i'm doing the tv it's like whatever
you're gonna make me look like you're
gonna make me look like when i'm in here
i'll just say whatever i want and you
know are they familiar with this do they
know you do this oh yeah no i've told
them multiple times when i got the show
i was like have you listened to my
podcast
have you listened to the history hiatus
have you listened to what
i've said on that show and they were
like yes we love it i was like
okay i hope you don't listen to episode
8
where
where i go over the pros and cons of the
nazis
this episode of king and the sting with
chrissy d
is brought to you by unleashed with
dingo and danny a new podcast fueled by
monster energy
unleashed gets up and close and personal
with the best in alternative
action motorsports get ready for untold
stories career defining moments and
inside secrets from the world's best
athletes and trailblazers
don't miss out on all the action new
episodes drop every two weeks
on mondays listen wherever you get your
podcast or watch
on monster energy's youtube unleashed
with danny and the dingo
fueled by monster energy yo man i get
hit up
all the time hey i'm trying to get my
diet right hey i'm too
thick i'll be part of the thick boy club
but right now i'm just the fat boy club
well guess what man today's program is
brought to you by athletic greens
the most comprehensive daily nutritional
beverage i've ever tried
right there's so many stressors in life
it's difficult to maintain
a correct diet right your body's just
jonesing from some for some nutrients
man because you've got a busy schedule
maybe you got bad sleep maybe you got
kid you can't get anything right
well you can get this right one tasty
scoop of athletic greens contain 75
vitamins minerals whole food source
ingredients including a multivitamin
so get rid of multivitamin just drink
this green drink dog
multi minerals probiotics prebiotics
green superfood blends and more
that all work together to fill the
nutritional gaps in your diet
we got you man athletic greens got you
covered all you gotta do
is simply visit athleticgreens.com kats
join the health experts
athletes podcasters comedians go-getters
around the globe who make a daily
commitment to their health
every day again all you got to do is
visit athleticgreens.com kats
get your free year supply of vitamin d
and five free
travel packs today what's this
we got the theater stinging it from a
fellow thick boy oh tlc 600 pound live
wow this guy would get softly kissed on
his lips
what's up guys uh quit keen this thing
for you
yummy bmi surgery
april 6 i got bmi surgery you know
before
my surgery i lost over 90 pounds i went
from 451 to now i'm 353 after surgery
skinny daddy um it just happened a
couple days ago i'm feeling a little
rough but
you know i heard pot while on here
talking about a shout out paul wall yeah
uh
sideways uh brandon really gave me
basically all the inspiration
in the world to uh try to get in shape
and just live and that's beautiful
so shout out to you shout out chappelle
for trying to lose weight too
[ __ ] you'll probably check out
everyone i literally
yeah [ __ ] this is a new side of life
and oh good for you thank you guys for
being with me
love
very positive guy um here's the thing
with that when you get that tummy
surgery when you you know they they make
your
uh stomach smaller okay my girls had
friends who have done it
and right they lose weight like right
away but if you're just so
fat and you keep eating it you're well
the staples will
it'll just go and then they're just
getting all the weight so went through
all that [ __ ] for no reason
yeah you still gotta say discipline dude
discipline and it's also i think it's
dangerous because if you eat if you
explode your stomach from the inside i
would imagine you're going to leak
fluids
i'm so jealous because i know some some
girls that got it done
and they'll come over our house and have
like one chicken wing like i am stuffed
i'm like oh i wish that was me because
i'm 27d
and i feel sick dude this kid yeah man
this kid
power to this kid i feel like um because
the bmi surgery because it's one of
those things where
you you can get that surgery and there's
like a stigma to get some people are
scared of getting the surgery some
really heavy people are like
because there's a chance you could die
on the surgery like your heart is
but either way you're going to go so
this is kind of like your last
do you want to just tell me swing let's
take a hail mary here maybe get it done
you ever watch the tlc 600 pound life
they go to that same doctor in houston
he has the gold [ __ ]
hearing [ __ ] he has the gold around his
neck yeah and every
it's i quit watching it because the show
is groundhog day yeah it's a fat person
they gotta drive all the way out there
they're in pain driving out there he
gives them a diet
and he tells them for six months you
gotta lose whatever 170 things over yeah
and then they come back and he's like
have you been sticking through the diet
and then they're like i was and he's
like well if you would you'd lose weight
they no one ever sticks the [ __ ] diet
it's the same thing every
time well what i think what i'd like to
know is i wish this guy would have told
us
what he ate the night before his his
surgery
because that must have been chaos that
must have been nuts um i mean
pizzas eating the box chicken wings ice
cream two liters of soda
i want to know how many calories he put
down have you ever seen the two uh
sisters the thousand pound sisters no
are they single uh
one is and has a forehead for days and i
think you'd be
you'd be damn up to it at christy comedy
hit me in those
dm's they're youtube stars okay but this
is how fat i am i will watch these two
sisters and when they eat i get hungry
right they were trying to lose weight
they made lasagna and she looks at the
other sister the one with the fat on the
forehead
she looks at her and the bottlenose
dolphin she looks at her and goes
uh should we put bacon in the lasagna
and she's like ooh that might be good
and then they slide bacon in between all
the lasagna see that's the thing is
it's like but but what that is is
is i mean that's it's really like it's a
physical thing but it's a ment
it's like a mental health disorder like
the eating you know it's all
about it's all emotion it's some
emotional thing so
i i don't know if like when they get
these bmi surgeries like they need to
then also be in like
psychotherapy 100 drugs or get over
whatever issue
they have that's causing him to eat
because i mean if you're you know not
even making fun of her but i mean if you
if you're if yours
got have you gained so much weight
you're getting fat on your forehead no
dude it's like
daddy issues no if you haven't that's
what that is yeah if you have a tricep
on your forehead we got we have some
issues
that's no good here's the other thing
that's curious on tlc i've seen way too
much of them
whenever there's like a 800 900 pound
girl there's always a
a real skinny boyfriend there's always
super chubby chasers on my friend justin
they're always super into it
yeah they like skin listen and and then
he's kind of hating he's like i don't
think it's gonna work this is dangerous
but he just wants to keep it real plump
listen i may have told you this before
but i'm i'm very attracted to chubby
indian women i like a nice chubby indian
woman
and and how chubby how indian
how i no i like i mean if they're like
all the way
like from india like india india
that's a plus but i like indian american
too but
i like i would say not that there's a
cut-off
but i mean you know i've dated indian
women who are 260 270.
yes yes i like a ch i like a chunky
indian
and that's just i don't even know honda
yeah yes and i don't know why
i don't know why some in your childhood
probably something my childhood i don't
and i've never really thought about
what it is but i do know that i find
myself quite often masturbating to
uh chubby indian women on point
it's dude it's own it's weird there's
probably not a lot of chubby indian porn
out there probably really i don't know
oh is it yes is it a whole you can find
oh yeah well no you haven't seen it nick
what come on google chubby and yeah
chubby indian women porn
or chunky indian women big black indian
yeah you know big indian women or if you
just watch some bollywood movies you
always got a nice you know what it would
uh big black so big indeed b iw b iw
big indian women yeah here we go see
yeah i'm just into you know just
i don't know what it is i you know what
i think it is i think
when i was like 20 21 i dated a girl
who was who was uh like an oh kind of
overweight indian girl and she was just
so good in bed that i
think freak i think that i thought that
all of them would be like that
but indeed they're not necessarily so
that's your style there
they love white men really they need i
don't know what i feel like that's
frowned upon no no they love
they secretly love white they love white
men a lot i when i was single there was
a lot of indian women not chubby
some chubby some not but a lot of indian
women would would would start a message
like
oh you know my father would kill me
found that i'm messaging you and i'm
like yeah well well you know
the price you're gonna pay them that's
what it is get these dick pics that's
what it is yeah i mean now does your
girl currently know that your soulmate's
a fat indian woman she
does know and she doesn't she's you know
what's interesting about my girl because
she's probably you know seven eight
months pregnant
she's at the point now she used to get
so mad at me all the time about
this who you're looking at whatever
she's also disconnected she doesn't care
anymore now too she can't she just got
to give in she's just like whatever like
these girls gonna like your pics i'm
sure you'll message some of them like i
don't care
i don't care anymore she's like i don't
care she's like just keep doing the
podcast let's get this house on long
island
just keep doing it and then they'll
cancel you just keep doing it
i think with our uh boy like you said
he's got to keep stay disciplined to
make it work we
we could check in on on him yeah i'd
like that that that's a fun adventure if
we if we meet him down he meets
us down 260 we fly him to the podcast or
something yeah hell yeah
oh yeah if he gets down 260 i'll fly him
out to la and you know what to you know
come in the culture corner
and we'll also get food yeah but celery
or some [ __ ] that would probably be i
bet she's never even been on a plane
before
i bet you that'll be one of his first
trips to fly you know so that's going to
be awesome to get him on that
if you get down 2-6 you can fly probably
give him his first flight first trip to
l.a yeah i'm gonna take him horseback
riding you can't do that when you're too
big either yeah there you go although i
was in uh montana i was on a horse named
the fridge
and he could probably handle that right
yeah yeah yeah oh
that's a jacked horse by the way
speaking of jack i saw chappelle put up
like 250 pounds 50 10 times damn
daddy yep i'm out here doing barry's
boot camp
i don't know why i don't come to the zoo
with us though because our boy mark
harley takes through a workout to
everybody getting [ __ ] jacked i'm
going to start coming in two weeks
because i got to do this [ __ ] show
where's the thick boy summer dog did you
go today we're going after this
right after another show have you seen
this guy mark hurley
is that the guy with the long hair the
jack ripped guys gorgeous gorgeous
distractingly good looking yeah he looks
like aquaman
he was in here on our cats after dark oh
was he really yeah and uh
and he we were all commenting on his
body like right when he walked in just
like jesus christ
and he was like you know it's a little
like you just don't want
to be looked at just for your look i was
like we look at you like a piece of meat
100
he's he's really is he so disciplined
diet-wise too and yeah he's super
disciplined also super gifted
genetically
right you know like he never plays
college football yeah
yeah football players always maintain
their jackedness oh
i don't know you don't think so
especially like the linemen when you
know like 360 pounds
then they get like super shredded or
they just blow
up blow up you know i feel like i feel
ugh
um i had wayne crabette you know the old
resort oh the receiver for the jet
jets dude he told me he told me that
he um when he came on my podcast he said
that
the lineman used to like for like in the
late first of all he told me if there
were camera phones in the late 90s
the entire new year would be canceled he
said new york jets no he said they'd be
in prison to this day they'd still be in
prison that's exactly what he said on my
podcast
edit that out he goes no no we we'd all
be in prison so yeah
and then he said that the he said that
the linemen over the course of the year
like to haze the rookies would shave
down the calluses
underneath their feet and put it in like
a cup
or shakes put it in like a cup and then
they would shred it over a salad and
make them eat it like like parmesan
cheese like parmesan cheese at the end
of the year and they all had to eat it's
assault brother
that's fully assaulted i'd rather just
pay for the lineman's dinner i know
that's what i said yeah and then
and then i was like so what else did you
guys do he was like no no he's like i'm
being serious he's like if i told you
what
we did on camera like we would
potentially go to prison wow i was like
okay wayne
well okay when couch catch it every
tuesday 11 a.m pretty chaos
they were good then though yeah yeah i
need to bring some of that [ __ ] back no
he just
sucks well that's what he and he told me
too he said he was it was fascinating
i had him on and then i had tiki barber
on and for for like nfl athletes to talk
about like what used to happen
like in the 90s and early 2000s like
even the [ __ ] talking
that used to go down like wayne like the
he was like the things that people would
say to each other get you canceled now
oh my god yeah he was like it was the
things on the field were
crazy i mean crazy like you know racist
sexist whatever wayne corbett was a boss
dude ballin you know what was awesome
about him he got this bar still handsome
or he looks like martin
he looks like mark norman no handsome as
[ __ ] dude
he's um and his son his son's his son's
a cutie
and um just waiting for him to turn 18.
and he and
he uh uh wayne corbett used to own this
bar
called krabetz on long island right
across the street from hofstra
university name
dude and they would let everybody in
with the underage id that
that was the spot yep well that's also
illegal so also illegal i also like
winker brett's style now
yeah i'm more of a fan you like wayne
corbett yeah yeah no he and he could
dude a white versus a
small slot white receiver oh yeah dude
dude oh yeah you're a unicorn these days
that's the thing dude and he's from new
jersey too
so he went to hofstra right he went to
hofstra yep and that's tough to make it
to the league out of there he played for
the
no because he's just all determination
he was just like he was just like yeah i
was just this little white
uh that julian elements kind of similar
to him you know he retired
why he had injuries he was dealing with
injuries all year and then finally the
patriots cut him he's like i'm done
anyways i'm gonna have tom brady so i'm
also a jewish guy julian adam you don't
see a lot of jews getting into
the sports talk about this me and him
we're cool now but i mean him almost got
a fight at a bar you and julian edelman
me and julian
i still am really close with tim tebow
and he didn't know me and tim were close
and we were drinking
we're with scotty mcknight and hidden
planetary so there's like you know it's
like this
yeah who's who there and for whatever
reason uh
tim gets brought up and he just starts
hating on him and he's one of my best
friends and i was like
you gotta chill so me and him start
arguing and then he said
something to me about well you ain't
gonna do [ __ ] and i'm like what
right what the [ __ ] yeah our friend and
then finally
my friend scottie camp was like hey dude
i feel like that's a time i was i think
ranked 11 in the world and you're going
to see that's a bad idea dude that i did
don't do that
we made up great dude has tim t tim
tebow's married now right yeah
so he's fine he's got that pun on
finally yeah good for him good for timmy
i mean remember there was that shot of
tim tebow
i remember on sportscenter when he was
just running across the field with no
shirt on with his pecs bouncing yes and
i remember just watching that on espn
just like first team all body
just staring at the yeah he he's one of
those guys where
he looked like because i know like you
know when he was playing college
football like this legendary athlete but
he looked like one of those guys
that was either gonna go the route he
went you know being like religious and
and following a thing
or you know you know kill people in a
manner kill his family
suicide all that stuff just snap
discipline for that but so far he's
going the right way most disciplined
person you've ever met in your life well
how so like
almost obsessive about it so like when
he was on keto it was like
dude i mean
he was doing keto before everyone
started doing it right see for me it's
always the weekends like on a saturday
or a sunday
my fight night saturday night my girl
makes you know some [ __ ] i'm like
what am i i'm not a competing athlete
yes i don't have a competition
right he's that [ __ ] chicken is tim
tebow still doing keto
i'm sure he's doing something yeah right
because he always just oh he's always
super disciplined does he live out here
uh no he lives this is tim tebow now
imagine you're like tim tebow
we actually got an update from tim here
he is between church
massey here coming at you from louisiana
i got a king interesting for you cheat
days uh
i'm an extra thick boy myself i started
out at about 390 pounds
um hired a trainer been going to the gym
trying to eat right oh yeah down to
about 350 about
four or five months um so
just want to know hey looking for a
little insight a little motivation you
know do i
take a day out of the week go eat all of
that good cajun food that i love to eat
some jambalaya maybe you know maybe an
extra help into that gumbo
yeah but uh keep going i don't know man
it's been tough it's been real tough
but i was listening to the podcast kind
of tired of brenda talking about how
he's a he's a big boy
meet me at 320 bro yeah yeah no you know
what
you look like one of them little look
like one of them little cups of cinnamon
butter you get a texas roadhouse
yeah yeah yeah you wish daddy love the
show
thank you guys love you man gang
buzz got them baby blue
yeah yo you can't be out here with baby
blues and bangs
yeah you got that beaver cut whoa
i didn't expect that dude i thought he's
gonna take off his glasses and have one
eye
at least at least the [ __ ] guy yo he hit
him with it but i think i think what
he's saying is
yeah did you need at least one day to
just i disagree okay
because here's the thing i'll see when
he says cheat days you mean every day
for him for a long time
so you don't have cheat days you have
cheat years yes and that's fine
so the thing is if if especially when
you first start dude you got to be super
disciplined there can be no cheat days
because
i'm sure he's like me because i have
that inner fat kid in me as well
where if i get one cheat day it it goes
it unravels avalanche i have to be
so strict well i can't be one foot in
one foot out are you so
super strict right now right now you
don't do it like what i did last night
with the possibility
never happened you would just would not
i would purge afterwards you would you
would truly vomit 100 i've done that
before so what do you do for a din din
at night when you're really hungry
last night i had chicken and uh half a
cup of white rice
that's just how you're rolling right now
that's how i'm rolling but when you put
on summer's coming down but when you put
on all the weight you well you said you
not all the way you said you put on 20
30 pounds in quarantine yeah you were
eating like a
like whatever i want you just you would
go now i have to be like
if i do a cheat day it just unravels
everything and then i'm out of whack
what if there's a football game on or
something what are you gonna eat can't
do it like you could have maybe
uh you could have like a little spoonful
let's say it's [ __ ] pie or some [ __ ]
like that but
you can't go full meals like especially
for him he's been cheating for so long
like his life is an entire cheat so when
you get this one you gotta stick to that
at least give yourself like six months
and then earn that cheat day
wow that's what i would say especially
at his level
interesting yes he's thick with five c's
see i
was only three but i was oh so you
because because i think the only diet
that seems to
work forever is that intermittent
fasting that's the only thing
for everybody though you gotta you you
get your blood work and they'll tell you
you know if intermittent fasting works
for you because it doesn't work for
everybody for
because for i was intermittent fasting
for years
and i met with my dietician nutritionist
mike dolce like how's that been working
for you
right i'm like yeah i'm the heaviest
i've ever been he's like yes so what do
you keep [ __ ] doing it really he's
like cause you
you know you don't eat til one in the
afternoon so you're starving your body
so your body's storing fat he's like and
then to make up for those calories
you're eating late at night
he's like he's like do me a favor for
the next few weeks start with a light
breakfast
have a snack lunch snack dinner snack
he's like see how that goes for you it's
been [ __ ] great
that's what it's been it's really about
just not eating late too as a big like
if you just stop eating at 8 p.m that
works right
kind of but even that like not for
everybody also your body's starving so
when you're starving your body your
body's storing fat
so you want to you want to fuel the the
machine so if you
want to get your metabolism burning just
eat healthy foods eat healthy like you
can eat it late at night but have
something healthy like an apple or some
like some vegetables or some [ __ ]
protein drink all right fine
fine that's what i'll [ __ ] do then
i'm sorry i ate buccatini yesterday like
dude you had i was eating it with my
hands my daughter was looking at me like
she thought i was
like having a seizure yeah but i because
i started myself but here's the problem
you don't want to be that dick on a diet
while your girl's pregnant
that's a problem too you don't want to
be that guy what are you doing dude i
know i know i've been
i've been comfort eating with her but
y'all shooting at tv but do you think i
look
cute or am i looking chunky no i think
you look cute dude i think
yeah my face looks okay yeah you look
good dude okay i think i have a mall i
need to have removed
no the mold gives you
yes and i see them all my grandma has a
mole like that on her [ __ ] face dude
yeah i know and i
try me a river doug i noticed that like
you know like even yesterday the makeup
lady she kept like putting powder on the
mall oh no leave them i was like what's
wrong with my moles she's like no it's
fine it's fine and it just did you get
sun
you know like they all sh i mean marilyn
monroe had a mole dog
she did have a mole and then she [ __ ]
got shot in the head oh no how did she
die maryland they say suicide everyone
thinks she uh
committed so she was hooking up with jfk
so yeah we got a relationship with vice
questions oh i love helping people out
me too what up king and the sting it's
your girl michelle
out here in wonderful cheyenne wyoming
oh that's the countdown i am submitting
a question today because
i have had debates about this in the
past so
my question how long until you can fart
in front of your significant other
people like me i say don't matter it's
natural people like my mom who's been
married for 36 years
still refuses to fart in front of her
husband i hold him
so talk about it let me know i'd love to
hear your thoughts on it
gang gang buzz buzz it'd be five she's
like gang gang buzz buzz
dude i think i think you have to fart in
front of
i say never what i've never farmed i've
accidentally where i'm like holding it
in you've never farted in front of your
girl
on accident i have but dude i keep it
sexy dude wow
keep it sexy at all costs so you don't
like when she when he's [ __ ] she
doesn't know
no i we have a separate bathroom like
you know what i'm doing but it's
and she's never farted in front of you
no never dude you're both going to die
of colon cancer
maybe i mean i it does hurt when you're
holding in that long but
never wow that's interesting when my son
farts my girl like what do you say he's
like excuse me i'm like i don't like
that though yeah cause that's
nerdy nerdy yeah if when he farts me and
him start laughing
yeah that's the move that's awesome yeah
no i rip
ass in front of my girl oh my god she
doesn't she never would
but i mean i'm talking about like like i
record my
farts like i fully record my farts and i
text them to her
yeah wait don't keep talking dude i
legitimately record my farts and text
them to her
often now let's just let's just let's
just put out what chris
offers to his girl yes you're you're
really attracted to
thick fat indian woman you should
probably be 100
you constantly fart around her yes right
yes
constant fart around her then you record
your farts i rec and text them to her
yes
and i text them with like titles like go
mets
and things like that and then she's like
oh what is what
and then it's just uh yeah i don't know
this girl's asking but uh she's
evidently single and she does it all the
time and her mom has been married for 36
years and doesn't do it so who's it
working for
i mean this one the first 48 probably
solved in about one second
that's a good point that's yeah i i mean
it's just not sexy like you don't come
on man yeah but
it's about being sexy it is in a
relationship though dude
you're comfortable around each other
enough
this one says live life
[Laughter]
the ones that are three to four seconds
let's say live life go mets
hey mom things like that and then it's
just good life
you're on set or what no dude that one
that one
i don't know i can give somebody a pink
guy dude that was from 2017
yeah no i'm 2017. yeah these are
stunning
dude there's one there's one if i could
find it dude [ __ ] i wish
if i could find it dude the one it was
literally
it was so crazy i sent it to i sent it
to
on a group text to to my girl my um my
child stepfather who's
uh an emergency room doctor my dad and
my
emergency room doctor friend called me
and was like are you okay
laughing no he was like he was like i
think you might have a blockage like i
would set up i'd like to set up a
gastroenterologist consultation and then
they did and i had to get a colonoscopy
oh wow i swear to god because he was
like
that he asked me all these questions you
have this fart on your phone from 2012
oh no that was okay that was just that
was something else i thought because it
said three seconds and it said
panchito's mexican restaurant
so i figured that's the one that's
happened this has to be yeah that's
go nuts that's the part go dude go mats
go ma yeah a [ __ ] dude i can't chin
i know you've never ripped a fart around
your girl ex-girlfriend you barely
sneeze
no i mean i've got to do it but really i
don't really
be like what's up babe i think girls
when they ask you to do it
they want to feel that bond even closer
my ex-girlfriend that's why she's like
we we're together for like
like two years now i think we should
fart this is the one by the way just
found the one this is wet
this is the one and it just says 90th
street i don't know why i thought it
would be funny
like i'm on the location but this is the
one because he said of the
sound of it and he said sweat the no
it's wet and he said the way
the way that it ramps up yeah like the
sound
ramps up he was like that that's
indicative here we go
so it's quick if you listen again and he
said the way
the way it's splattered yeah yeah he
said he was like you know that's
hilarious like you're funny guy whatever
he's like but i i thought very cool but
i i think you have
going on down there i genuinely want to
check if you have polyps he's like so
let's just get to that
yeah like oh thank you but so that's
that's how i am is i just send
the farts because for me it's like not
only is it like you know whatever we're
all just people health but i just feel
like
if she can you know deal with me farting
and my [ __ ] and all
like i clogged the toilet a couple of
days ago like full
[ __ ] to the brim of the toilet it's
actually on my patreon page
you have to get your deuce big glow on
and [ __ ] no she did it
she clocked into it and was taking care
of a pregnant girl yes and i didn't ask
her to do it
it's just i because i don't really know
how to fix anything and i was just
looking for a plunger for like an hour
puerto rican and her just going to town
because i just didn't want to do it
she's like give me the [ __ ] plunger
and then and then she did it and i was
like why are you doing this why are you
doing this and then my guy the homeless
pimp
who was staying with me last week
because we were filming my podcast just
filmed they're just
[ __ ] eat just plunging clumps of my
[ __ ]
yeah dude but that's what she but she
doesn't care but then she literally she
does though
she does no but she does but she does i
don't know she does we had sex this
morning
you should release uh that archive of
all the farts on vinyl
i should make him an nft ah that's what
it is dude make money my farts are an
nft
i'm living nick you look like a farter
uh yeah
yeah it's it's like my girlfriend
doesn't fart in front of me at all i'm
with the door open
like yeah [ __ ] a little too comfortable
dude like this one's going to be loud
let her know
yeah yeah i don't record them yeah it
should it's fun to record them because
i just think it put for me i just think
it puts a thing in the relationship
where it's like
if you can be with me like through
sickness and through health it's like
you've heard some of these farts
sickness so you're going if you're going
to stay with me through that
then i think that i think there's a
little bit of respect level too i want
some
[ __ ] to stay what i think about you
you're not it's
you're there's not an honesty in a
relationship if you're not gonna fart
it's like oh
cause i would say okay you don't want to
fart from me what else are you hiding
from me
what else because i know it's coming out
of your butt that's how i would think
about it
interesting yep it goes back to marilyn
monroe if you can't handle me at my
worst you don't get me at my best
that's what it is sure that's what it is
now chain you had a girl that wanted you
to fart for
for my ex-girlfriend after like a couple
years she was like we should probably
fart in front of each other to be closer
yeah
it's like a barn thing yes yeah sure
yeah hey chin how many times did you
[ __ ] on her no
[ __ ] on her we literally went brown and
it felt weird afterwards
are you guys together i bet it was so
awkward
you're like really and she's all
pertinent
yeah yeah hearing it come out of her was
kind of it was a little weird wait how
does your girl respond when you send her
the messages
when i send her the messages usually she
there's no response
there's just no response i mean she
doesn't like it chris she doesn't care
but like when
because the thing is too like when i
like rip like an insane fart like out of
like the top of my ass crack which is
hard to do
a lot of people come at the bottom
there's sometimes where i fart i don't
know why it travels up like an elevator
and it almost like rattles my tailbone
and the kids
die laughing like fall out of there
there's nothing funnier than a fart to
kids dude they're falling out of their
car seats so that makes my girl laugh
and she's like
we're such a happy family because i'm
just ripping [ __ ] in a seat dude my
one-year-old he you know he doesn't know
it's just in their bones man he'll fart
and he'll laugh his ass off yeah dude
it's just and it's in our dna but see
but that's but that's but that's
even just what you said if literally our
factory setting
as children is to laugh at the fart why
do we need to change that then as adults
is because because there's some things
that you don't have to
show how the sausage is made in
relationship there's something like
me my girl keep it sexy at all times i
guess
like even in the house like i don't wear
like frumpy clothes she don't wear
frumpy clothes
like she'll wear sexy like like pajamas
and like
i'm not in just like [ __ ] clothes around
the house what the hell
dude this is psychotic what are you
talking about
really you're not like so you don't like
i won't leave the house in sweats
i won't let anybody see me in sweats
unless i'm working out
what the [ __ ] is are you there's a
standard you [ __ ]
what dirtball what do you live in an
abercrombie and fitch
like your home with the kids why not
just you know
when you're the kids i'll let it loose
but when your wife's home
you know you don't see her no makeup you
know hair up in a bun making bacon
yelling at everybody like that she does
that
but she's but she's not dressed like a
[ __ ] bum but she
what do you mean so you make her i don't
make her do anything she'll wear like a
like a sports bra oh i feel like youtube
i feel like you're running a [ __ ]
middle eastern household you're running
you're doing like i'm running apple
yeah no you know you're right it's like
it's like you know sweatshop she's got
to look a certain way and the men gets
everything and you she better not come
down those stairs
not looking hot no not that not that i'm
going to meet her we're going to have
our family
i'm going to talk her in i'm going to
i'm going to get inside her and i'm
going to roll don't say get inside oh no
yeah
i didn't mean to say that i might say
get inside her mentally because don't
back me in corner make me [ __ ] your
pregnant wife
dude literally you versus my pregnant
wife i'm not you would think you'd win
but i'm genuine no i don't i'm sure
no yeah i'd have to see her because
she's would be able dude how about this
my this little it was actually
terrifying but i couldn't believe
like how like pregnant women's bodies
and minds just go into a place to
protect the baby this is true a few days
ago it was like six o'clock in the
morning it was easter
six o'clock in the morning we went uh in
my trunk we had gotten some um like
easter eggs for the kids or whatever
and you know we're hot you know putting
gonna put it out like an easter egg on
for them like when they woke up
and we we just moved into this new place
and there's like this step
that she didn't realize was there and
she's
walking with the easter egg uh uh box
right in front of me and she trips and i
it was like slow motion
watching her trip and to protect
to protect her stomach if she wasn't
pregnant she would have just fallen it
would have been fine
to protect her stomach i watched what
she did she protect and like flip in the
no dude she went literally she was like
parallel to the floor she skyrocketed
her body and smashed her head
off the cement the baby wall outside our
house
and landed on her back like she was like
literally like bleeding from her head
and had like a black eye it looked like
i beat her that's sexy but she i know
yeah had yeah i think we had no we
didn't have sex at night yeah but she
because she had a concussion
also pregnant sex
but she but dude i couldn't believe how
like her body
just like instinctively was like protect
the baby so i think if you found her
in a ufc match and you and you tried to
hit her with like a gut shot
she'd kill you yeah she would just know
what if she would just figure out a way
to
mess with her yeah yeah so but i think
when our families hang out i'm gonna i
need to have a talk with
our families need to talk about the
differences between us and how we can be
more similar
agree yeah okay good it's gonna be good
hey papi
mother's day is coming up maybe it's
your girl's birthday and you want to get
them something nice so go to
bluenile.com all right
you can celebrate all of life's special
moments from creating the custom
jewelry that you want we got you covered
bluenile.com
it has prices you won't find a
traditional jeweler all right
we got everything man whether she
prefers a statement piece
or an everyday subtle kind of piece
bluenow.com has fine jewelry for every
mama mother's day is coming up man
so mark mother's day was something
really nice classic diamond stud
errands elegant tennis bracelets
birchstone pendants so much more at
bluenile.com
see what all the people are talking
about blue now has over 165
000 ratings and counting with nine
percent at four stars or
higher man blue now is committed to
ensuring the highest
ethical standards are observed when
sourcing diamonds and
jewelry this mother's day give mom
something she will freak out over
all right give her blue nile bluenow.com
you guys get 50 off your purchase over
500
this is a podcast exclusive only for you
cats listeners and viewers use the code
kats
that's code kats plus every order is
insured ships free
and arrives discreet little package so
it doesn't give away the surprise
shop stress free on bluenile.com today
this guy's got a king understand it for
us
hey what's up theo what's up onion
where'd you even buy that shirt
where would you buy that shirt i
honestly genuinely my heart believe he
bought that at a cvs
do you think cbc or or at a trump rally
100 yeah hey what's up the uh what's up
onion
um this is clark from bisbee arizona
um you can my friends call me clark and
so i want to say this guys what do you
guys think king it or sting it
you know um
what do you think about these underwater
births
of babies a lot of women now you see him
having that uh
that drippy kitten you feel me and um
so or or do you like that old-fashioned
that dry rub
so that's what i'm saying underwater
births
or that regular just straight into the
air animal
gang buzz buzz
love it dude the dry rub i like the
dryer that one that was a
tough obstacle for theo to get through
that one
buzz buzz yeah it looked like it hurt
for him to get that out oh it did
it did he i think i would do underwater
birthdays like
you're doing that at home though in the
bathtub i know that's the point it's
221.
yeah why the [ __ ] giving birth at the
crib in the crisp
i know i'm a big fan of the c-section or
you guys ruined the vagina
and it's it's like the kid for sure
comes out ready to go like even if he's
upside down or his record they get them
out
and there's a time like when when i know
that they want to do it natural but
women do
you know they're in labor for 46 hours
like you know we could just take care of
this like dude
my kid when my daughter was born my
first daughter was born
her uh mom went into the delivery room
no epi son no epidural just went in
full 1700s giving birth
and now now is your girl from the movie
apocalypto yes
dude she's just she just [ __ ] white
knuckled it
and she dude we're flying home we're
flying home
uh like may 24th of may 25th my kids do
dates like
july 4th like she could potentially give
birth that's not
i didn't think you could even fly no her
doctor her doctor doesn't give a [ __ ]
her doctor's like dude you could do it
that's those new york doctors
and that's why her entire nation shut
down things i know but i'm i'm
so nervous about it flying home but
she's like she was like what if
if it happens i'll just give birth her
sister her sister gave birth
in their house like unexpectedly didn't
even call the doctor
sisters and her mother delivered the
baby and then they went to the hospital
they called 9-1-1
dude that's what it is they're gangsters
gangsters dude puerto rican yes yep
all right apocalypto wow good movie
apocalypse hate reference yeah
look at this kid this guy's roofie
somebody
for sure hey guys this one's for debate
club uh what's more interesting dave
portnoy sex tape or
bad babies only fans ooh good question
question question man
very good question he feels like a
makeup shark um
man have you seen portnoy sex i didn't
see point noise sexting it's pretty
good is it good yeah he's got moves uh
well no it's kind of it's it's very um
it's very american psycho okay she's
like she he has a belt around her
neck hot girl and i forget who she's
cambria can't watch it right probably
uh we'll watch it just so you just for
your edification it won't go on the
episode
okay but also nick's gonna jack off
not not my style not okay it's
aggressive
okay because because i but
she said that everything was fine like
she has no problems no story but there's
also no story here besides
this really you know successful guy who
owns barstool had sex with a hot chick
that's a narrative like she even came
out i was like consensual i agreed to it
i knew it was being filmed
yeah me and him are still good he's good
and then his
one of the stocks that he's in with went
down
and so he was like oh hell no because i
had consensual sex and the video came
out right so he's like i'm telling
everybody buy this now what's low it's
going to go back
up holy [ __ ] so yeah because i feels
like people are trying to cancel porn
but you can't
but what are you gonna what are you
gonna take from him they both agreed to
have this sexual intercourse
yeah and then the video leaks how does
the video leak though
who knows you think she did no i don't
because how do you even but also
for his brand it actually makes him more
yeah
he's more lovable to his fan base yeah
yeah that makes sense so there's no
problem with that and then the bad
baby thing they're not canceling they're
not trying to kill i haven't seen
anything cancel not cancel but like i
feel like
brands might be like oh this is too much
like obviously paul pierce lost his job
because
he had a party at his house and had
strippers and he loses his job
nba hall of famer he his job well
barcelona will hire paul pierce i want
i want paul pierce to work for that
that's oh that's what we're gonna do
perfect
i love dave portnoy he's he's one of
those guys where like you know you seem
around like new york a lot and it's like
i know some people like oh he's [ __ ]
a dick it's like why
because he doesn't talk to you he's a
[ __ ] businessman making millions of
dollars
he doesn't want you on bar stool [ __ ]
you you're not good enough yeah what do
you want me to tell you what
the guys that are like that demeanor or
can come off it
i don't give a flying [ __ ] it doesn't
bother no i actually ego's not that
sensitive but he can be uh you know
tough
dude i went into barstool to pitch a
show pitch like a podcast show
in his office and he just said no and i
was just like you know what
you're right this show sucks like i it
was wonderful time man where it's like i
know some of my peers would like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] to go twitter i was like now
dude i didn't have a good idea
so good for you yeah i was just like
yeah so no
you'd be great for them no i go on the
barstool shows a lot
in new york but i i wanted like to be
and they were like no whatever
here he is there he is oh puppet very
american psycho
very nice
he grabs her face like that that's no
good right
you think he's using a candy no no you
don't you don't make
oh then he spit on her yeah
love it so that's so crazy how that gets
pretty
though that is pretty hot it's wild but
you know what it does
i will say this though i will say this
again to each their own
like you said consensual all good
whatever people are into but i wonder if
it gets to a point
do you think he was doing stuff like
that with the belt spitting on girls
before this or like when you get so
powerful
and famous like you just have to do
things like that to get you off there
you go because it's fine because i think
maybe in college or something or high
school he probably wasn't the guy that
got chicks like this
now he has 400 million dollars in the
bank he scrooge mcduck
so that's going to bring these type of
girls so he can do that so he's having
he's having the time of his life and
that's kind of the way it goes yeah
because you know what and also too while
i'm thinking about it everyone's like oh
dave
maybe who know maybe the girl was like
put a belt on me and spit on me maybe
dave doesn't want to do that
maybe either way she was into it because
that belt didn't get on her neck by
herself and like you said who gives a
[ __ ] people have weird
kinky stuff honestly i mean he's not
army hammering it
yeah he's not trying to eat her toe off
okay and it's like to be honest with you
if i told you
if i told you what he thinks weirder if
you had no idea what sex even was if you
had never even
heard of any type of sex movement i was
like what's weirder putting a belt
around your neck
and having sex with you or making get on
your knees and me coming on your face
you'd probably say come on the face sure
would be weirder that's pretty standard
i was gonna say it's just more accepted
in society because that's whatever
reason
yeah yeah yeah yeah and with bad
bad uh barbie bad baby bad baby it's
like
i guess she's 18 right so we'll be a
little careful but at least she's 18
broke the only fan's all-time record a
million in like six hours
i don't so he's saying what's better
dave's sex today what's more interesting
to you dave sexton
dave sexy i mean listen uh uh an
attractive 18 year old star and only
fans all right
welcome to the [ __ ] club whatever and
it's also like how much different can
the only fans be of like some of these
girls instagrams where they're half
naked anyway what's the difference but
one there's no
difference but now if you want to see it
you got to pay for it oh what so only
fans what so on and only fans what she
gets like completely naked
is that what it is i think that the one
thing she showed her tits
but also theo was in a video playing a
pedophile with bad babies
no this is a 10 out of 10 though so
so they let theo ad-lib this and like
you know improv it
yeah and he called her a wigger yeah and
they edited it out
but he had his team filming it so he has
that footage
this is not like a fan made that's like
no was actually in the band baby
he auditioned to play a pedophile they
went you're perfect
and then he got the gig that's amazing
but they let him like because she ties
him up and like kills him in the end or
beats the [ __ ] him
and and uh they go you can just ad lib
and he's like you know supposed to
say bad stuff to her and he goes you
freaking wigger
and they're like cut hey
pedophiles that's enough freaking
wiggler
what an idiot so [ __ ] i love theo so
much me too
look at that look at that yeah dude i
didn't know he was really in the video
that's amazing yeah man there he is
could not look any more like a pedophile
dude the only movie i ever did
i actually even forgot the name what was
the name of it
i forgot the actual name of it but i
would i my part
my part was called staten island
douchebag that was the part
what the [ __ ] was it it was with martin
freeman where morgan freeman no
martin freeman the guy the guy from uh
geeks freaks and geeks and no no martin
freeman the guy who played the hobbit
martin you've seen martin freeman before
oh he's one of the hobbits one of the
short guys and it was difficult oh yes
and it was one of the movies it was a
movie where like he forgets
ode to joy ode ode to joy
i'm i'm out on all oh dude i never
here's the thing
i never even saw something that's
horrible i forgot i even did a part
and it was the only movie i've ever been
in and i forgot i even did a partner i
didn't even remember i did a partner
there was a time where me and my um you
know current girlfriend we broke up
for a little while we broke up for like
a year and a half and she went started
going out with somebody else i started
going out with somebody else
and she calls the very first movie
this guy took her to see was this
[ __ ] movie
she was like it was literally ruined the
date she texted me
dying she was like i'm dying laughing
right now yeah staten island meathead
yeah yeah dude look at your [ __ ]
picture
dude that literally i swear to god my
friend vinnie
was taking a photography class and took
that headshot from me and that's what
they use on my imdb
look at me he's like you gotta look you
gotta look sophisticated for your
headshots put on a tie
does that guy sell molly i don't know
yes he does
that guy's on bad babies only fans yeah
um so
so but did you have a speaking role yes
sorry speaking also my part was
the the they i was jogging past him
on uh the bqe uh like um um uh the
promenade which is like this beautiful
part of the
brooklyn queen's expressway you can look
out and see manhattan it's like this
beautiful [ __ ]
so we're like jogging and i was supposed
to bump him and then
like heckle him right and and the
director was like just come up with some
heckles yeah
you know so i was like doing them what
you know whatever and then one of the
heckles
well actually the first heckle i did
where they were like no you can't do
that because this is another movie
he hit me and i was like you [ __ ]
hobbit and he was like no
don't shout out no reference is the lord
of the rings no references of his old
movies and then i just
couldn't come up with i just kept saying
that was yeah
every time i'll be [ __ ] bilbo bagging
homo you know like i was just like
dude there were no things they genuinely
started to get mad at me yeah like you
know like i just couldn't and i
something happened in my brain martin
freeman though was laughing
hard really he was laughing dude and he
told me so many stories to
and i only didn't get paid no no he got
[ __ ] hey
martha dude the hobbit movies he went to
new zealand for like that's where they
filmed
for like 18 months and they i think they
actually gave him the no i broke your
thing
i think actually he i think it was him
he told me they gave him the entire
movie salary like in one paycheck up
front so i was like
and then he was but you know what's
interesting what he told me which was
kind of like
a little you know again i'm not you know
i don't know that i have any aspirations
i would do a movie why the hell not but
he was like you know the thing with the
movie businesses
and television he was like i you know
when i did the hobbit it was fantastic i
had a great time you know
it's a [ __ ] multi multi multi-million
dollar maybe a billion dollar movie
he's like but i have to be away from my
family for 19
20 months he's like so people don't
understand like when you watch like
leonardo dicaprio winning a war or
it looks so glamorous and it is he's
like but what it comes with is like
missing all your kids baseball games but
leonardo dicaprio doesn't have family
there's a reason why he's a
bachelor playboy for that reason for
that reason it was like um
so yeah yeah but he was it was at least
you had speaking lines i auditioned for
tax collector david ayers move with
shiny buff
so in in the audition crush it they're
like yeah we're definitely using i'm
waiting for a callback to give me a call
back i'm like [ __ ] yeah
so i get there and my character's name
was negro
and so yeah easy so um i played a
mexican cartel member
and i had lines but then for whatever
reason
you know they're like right dude i know
the reasons you can't read
no i can't speak dude i can't though i
didn't even know you could speak until
you started doing podcasts
like this guy [ __ ] talks
i thought he just ripped people's heads
off no man this is like
two years ago three years ago yeah so i
go on uh
set they get me in this full like narco
[ __ ] get up i look
so ridiculous there's pictures of alex
already have the hat on
and then they give me a gun i'm like
this thing's sick yeah just give me sick
i'm gonna like do my line
like oh no we're actually the the cartel
guys the security you're not gonna speak
you're just gonna shoot
shia and then do this thing i'm like
okay but they gave me these
this mask and in my head i'm like oh
[ __ ] nobody's gonna notice me man yeah
this [ __ ] mask on
so i was like i'm just gonna take it off
see what they say so you know action i
come out i'm like yeah yeah yeah like
cut hey negro mask on i'm like oh yeah
my bad
yeah so i put the mask on though i don't
take it off again so
get get cut god damn it put the mask on
so i gotta leave the mask on do that my
cry
the next you know it's gonna be dope no
next thing's just me standing for
[ __ ]
yeah like this for 30 minutes while shia
labeouf's
given some great performance yeah that
was it dude
and movie suck clock i was gonna say
you're probably on set for [ __ ] a
year too right
i was on set for four days four or five
days
got to know the cast which is cool to
see like how the sausage is made in
hollywood and shiloh buffs
how many times are you going to say how
the sausage just made that's the second
time that's the second time
is that the name of the episode how the
sausage is yes there's the episode
yes but you know what i realized beyond
that set unless it's like a comedy buddy
movie with like all our
crew i'm not into it man yeah yeah was
shia labeouf cool though
he was dope yeah so [ __ ] talented oh
you know you dude
i would have to watch him die over and
over i'm like what a terrible gig
dude the best actors are the ones who
like could be legitimately like in a
mental institution
people suit this so he played uh
it's based off true story he's a white
guy that collected for the cartel
in uh south central l.a this is a true
story so he played the white guy that
would collect for the gangs back in
mexico okay
so his rival this rival gang had like
their
cartel members thugs with them were
eaten at craft and service and the guy
come you know just a regular mexican
dude like a
stunt coordinator who they got up as a
[ __ ] cartel guy
he's like making this [ __ ] thing and
try cuts in front
and the guy's like doesn't say you know
he's a nice like he's a dad
yeah and he's like oh i guess you're
shooting cunning what the [ __ ] you say
to me
and the guy's like you're just gonna cut
in line and he calls him by his
character name
and the guy's like wait what's happening
and then just gets in a full-blown fight
with him
and it shuts down shooting for like two
days what like a fist fight yeah
he's like you and he starts throwing
references like in the movie
he's like well you need to give you know
[ __ ] darito back his [ __ ]
i'm like what is happening right now wow
what
nice [ __ ] i like that though where
like because i'm sick and tired of when
you see
things like when a actor like is you
know
yelling on set just being a maniac to
like the key grip guys or the camera
guys i'm like why doesn't one of these
guys
take a [ __ ] crowbar and level this
[ __ ] because they'll never work
again yeah but who cares about that
you do that to tom cruise you're [ __ ]
getting shipped
walk my words right now on this podcast
clip it i'm gonna get in a movie with
tom cruise one day and beat the [ __ ] out
of him on set
oh i'm gonna do it i feel like tom
cruise
put it on because guess what's going to
go up the podcast now yeah
yes maybe yeah you're going to keep
calling him ethan hunt
yeah yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] who's this brooks
wheeling who's this
he looks like that ufc fighter who's on
ultimate fighter
has the red afro yeah lewis pena fights
this weekend
yep walmart or
target and you can't say amazon because
you know that ain't fair
keep doing what y'all doing man help me
get through today i love it buzz gang
buzz gang young man walmart i've worked
too hard to shop at walmart
yeah walmart and target in woodland
hills dude if you're single if you're a
single
male in l.a you need to go to this
target
target as my mom used to caught when i
was a kid because that was fancy you
need to go to tarjay of woodland hills
off de soto
the work is there everyone has a blood
ass everyone's latina
it's fantastic yummy yummy all right i
pretend my kid
we bought my kid a toy and he was like
oh thanks dad but she does the
the returns yeah so i was like hey just
you know spark conversation okay
so this toy he doesn't like it and he's
like dad i like shut the [ __ ] up like so
the thing is
yeah just trying to start a conversation
see that's the thing about out here or
like you know like or wherever this
man's from is the target and the
walmarts
that's not a thing in new york city like
there is one target but there's no i've
never i've i've been in a walmart maybe
three times in my life
because in new york man everything's in
the bode there's no room for walmart in
new york it's just everything's in the
bodega dude
like but whatever you need but also
you're kind of fortunate we have to do
that
and but here's another reason you moved
to l.a dude and just work with me
is we have targets we have targets
also that paycheck targets yes yes
but i don't know but i don't know i see
even like with the target i guess so but
i guess i had to pick one
for this kid i would say target feels a
little bit
you're doing a little bit better in life
target's upper upper brow
walmart is like walmart are where the
mutants from table seven come from yeah
walmart is tough yeah walmart is it
that's rough but uh yeah so i would say
i would say i'd go to a dude tarjay you
can get
dope food now you can get a fresh out
fresh ass outfit they'd sell junk food
clothing there
and get dope tvs video games toys for
kids
all right like you're close to me go
that target dude take your kids there
they have
it's like toys r us dude you just said
they're [ __ ] hot latinos with fat
asses you want me to go in there with my
pregnant
puerto rican girlfriend are you kidding
me i didn't say bring her i said
ditch her and i think i could do
anything without her besides a podcast
and
farting no chance dude yeah no she's got
do they sell guns in target
no no all right well then i'm a little
safe because if because she would you
know my girl is the type of girl like
she just you know
they do sell weights though ah okay
she's protesting
hit me with anything yeah video games
there go pros
almond milk cards okay
they got them goods they got everything
they got do they have the vaccine
not the john city judge sid we'll do one
more king of it or sting it
okay
what's up deal what's up brendan boy tio
again the guy under the house the
illegal oh
you know that guy who's hiding uh from
mike i got a king
of stinger for you guys man what's y'all
thinking about that cowboy [ __ ] talking
about that nitty gritty stuff
talking about that drinking beer all
[ __ ] damn working cows
elbow deep oh
what's he looking for let me know what
you boys think rusty bread
yeah what do you say anyways let me know
what you think cowboy [ __ ] king of the
stinging
gang gang buzz buzz oh they're trying to
impregnate dude that's some real
man [ __ ] damn that's man [ __ ] we not
built for that life
yeah all day on your feet [ __ ] around
them cows farting left and right
then you gotta get elbow deep and that
cow's [ __ ]
and what is it and what's the what are
they doing there they're trying to
impregnate them oh that's a vagina
but how but how do they do what are they
fingering i guess they have some sort of
semen and they shove it all the way down
there
that's crazy you can look it up it's a
fistful full of
[ __ ] and he just [ __ ] fists that poor
cow
why does that work with humans like i
wonder if that would work with humans i
bet it could work
it's like you know you're like you're
with your wife and you just can't get
her pregnant what about this
you just call this guy up and he just
gets in there with a fistful of your
jizz anyone been on a farm
i bend it with them i can't but i don't
understand
what woke up at like 4 00 a.m and then
got the hay or what the [ __ ] they do
with the rooster crows and you know what
a lot of i mean the cow is just
taking it dude the cow's not even moving
the chow likes it tell you what i've
always want to do is just milk a cow
dude i just like
you want to milk it why don't you do it
dude there's not a lot of cows
in l.a what are you talking about they
got farms in l.a we could get you a cow
all right let's do it let's [ __ ] milk
a cow dude chrissy d and
big b go [ __ ] cow tipping i wanna i
would a thousand percent do that
youtube content yes that's where my
ghost
you know youtube youtube yeah yeah i
just want to get on that calendar
dude i mean this is this is wild these
guys you know what it's called
what so i just looked it up and said uh
well the reason why they do is
because it helps them produce more milk
when they impregnate them
okay and the thing they use the device
is called a rape rack
a rape rack well they shove it all down
21. it's in 2021 it's still called a
rape rack
not from peta by left get a hold of this
naming they're gonna change that real
quick but i wonder if that
i wonder if rape rack was in existence
first
like and then that's why they call rape
it's from this i wonder
what came first the rape rack or the
rape the rape okay
the rape yeah yeah no i think i think
ray i think the term rape
comes from rape it has to i don't think
so i'm with you no i don't think so
i mean think about it for i mean how
long have guys been raping
yeah but how long has there been a term
for it but how long have we been eating
cows
and drinking cow milk i i assume someone
got raped before they ate a cow
yeah good point i don't know
yeah yeah i don't know either i don't i
would assume dude yeah like back in that
old ancient
chinese times you don't think they were
taking societies over and raping each
other so what are they supposed to call
it then a
no no a non-consensual rack what are you
supposed to call this you have to call
it that
uncomfortable rag uncomfortable rack i
mean damn dude the
cow looks thick too thick ass and he's
just in there my man is just in there
that's what he does dude that's his job
that's his job we we do this he does
that what do you think his arm smells
like when it comes out
what would you rather do stick your
elbow would you rather go elbow deep in
that cow's ass or eat another gooey duck
elbow deep in that cow's ass okay i do a
gooey dog that gooey duck i
was disgusting you know i had to go
straight to the set of that true tv show
right after that smelled like gooey duck
all day
like just stuff we smelled like [ __ ]
dude don't have to go straight from this
to shoot for showtime
yeah i'm engaging with fans doing this
what's up segment where they call
in and my staff was like what is what no
no would you have red lobster eating raw
fish dude 100 i literally feel like
[ __ ] dude i
i literally got i facetimed with my girl
right as soon as i let her say listen
this is gooey duck you're gonna see the
video
i was on nick's ass i was like you need
to give me that gooey duck clip you need
to give me that gooey duck clip
i gotta send it to her because i was
like i'm gonna come home and have to
immediately take a shower after work
which is usually like a no-no it's like
you gotta i gotta stand there i gotta
come in and she's gotta sniff me to make
sure i didn't cheat
and then and then i could take a shower
and and disrobe but i was like i'm gonna
have to get home and immediately disrupt
i don't know what's up because i had the
gui duck and i gotta work all day did
you ever hear about that i
forget what nfl might have an mba or nfl
player but he was cheating on his girl
so much when he'd walk in the door his
girl would smell his dick
sure that's probably a lot of guys you
think what do you mean
i feel like if your girl has skin on her
knees and smell your dick every time you
go out to [ __ ]
7-eleven you should probably end it it's
probably you
the trust is gone yeah but she's such a
good cook and she's hot you know like
she's hot she loves
it's just she's great yeah it's tough
it's tough dude it's tough
it's tough and there's nothing i can do
to get away from it her because
like i said if i she's already you know
cleaned out my [ __ ]
[ __ ] toilet here go back yeah oh there
we go keep going back keep going back
keep going back keep going because it's
that scene uh
keep going keep going on the bridge
that's the bridge yeah so she's
she's very attractive it's right before
yeah go back go back go back
yeah because it's right before he gets
thrown up
i think here go go that's it i think
when we get to the bridge when i get to
that bridge yeah she's beautiful this
girl but i never met her that's the
thing with a movie
it's like people don't lose each other
you don't you only know see the people
you saw
in that [ __ ] scene you know
yeah like when they do cartoons yeah
that's me look thank you new york yeah
what'd you just say to me you have a
farmer's dan
i know they didn't give a [ __ ] yeah
what's i don't even know what the clip
they took was
what'd you just say to me oh
watch it [ __ ] back thank you new york
what'd you just say to me watch it ship
back that's the one that they picked
oh dude that was the whole scene that
was the whole and how long were you on
set for
nine days nine days two or three days
yeah did probably 300 takes
and they picked what's up [ __ ] bag
probably adr because they couldn't get
one where you weren't saying bilbo
baggins
yeah yeah dude i don't even i genuinely
don't even know if i ever even got paid
like i have no idea how long ago was
that
two years ago why'd you have a farm
stand i know do i what do you think do i
look better then or better now way
better now you think i look like a
chunky people you look like [ __ ] there
i look like a little chunky monkey did
you have to go sleepless i get some meat
watch it [ __ ] back
thank you new york yeah it looks brutal
there right
it's just like a doe of [ __ ] yeah like
no
tone at all like just i need i need lap
band surgery there
weird jump cut here yeah very strange
watch it [ __ ] bag oh watch it [ __ ] back
thank you new york very strange yeah
yeah yeah this is one of those we got a
much better body now
yep oh thank you the the the martin
freeman
it's interesting like when you see these
guys do these movies like i bet you he
doesn't even remember doing this movie
no
like he they do so many like they do but
it's like we do podcasts
but it's yeah how we do podcasts how we
do you know certain tournaments
yeah like someone go oh you remember
last year when we were here in san diego
where i'm like
not really dude like i don't unless it's
a real big moment i don't really
remember i don't remember that's all
that you're doing
so much i guarantee you this kid doesn't
remember a
second of this movie and he was filmed
for like four months
yeah what do you think he got paid for
that that something like that if i had
to guess they probably threw him like a
million dollars
i would imagine because you're not going
to get martin freeman to sho
the guy was the hobbit he's not going to
do the movie if it's a low-budget movie
it's because the majority of the budget
has to go to your start yeah but isn't
he kind of typecasted as the hobbit so
like i'm not trying to see him in a
romantic comedy for sure do magic can
have big feet
yeah that's true too i know like
yeah you know like you flow from the
[ __ ] progressive progressive
commercials started doing romantic
comments like you better sell me
insurance
tell me insurance yeah that's true
that's true yeah i don't know man i uh
i uh i don't know i met him he was good
i
you know if he i just know because what
i heard on the because we've had the
other one who's really into bugs and
animals on one of the hobbits
so there's the one main hobbit who ain't
doing podcasts
right and there's freeman doing romantic
comedies then there's the other guy
forget his name
we've had him on the podcast before you
remember chin yeah i'm finally kids not
rudy is it
not rude he's not lost he was on his
exhaust so he's done some big [ __ ]
but he was i was like dude so he's like
flying private or do you have like a
magic carpet
and he's like no he's like they like
they knew because from the books that
this series would be
[ __ ] huge so they tie you in their
contract
and they don't even know if they're
gonna make six or seven of them but do
you sign the contract day one
right you make all seven so no matter
how well they do we get paid this much
right he's like so we're not as rich as
you think i think that's what he said so
i feel like your friend uh morgan
freeman's lying
i know i know who's more who's rich or
martin fr
google martin freeman's net worth i feel
like martin freeman's net worth
is it's got to be in the schmidly it's
about 20. 20 mil
i was thinking martin starr earlier yeah
i think there's a story too in that in
the game of thrones series
the the first season the character
who gets beheaded i forgot his name the
well aquaman said he
while he was shooting game of thrones he
was living out of a van dude
in malibu really yeah he was like i
didn't like i wasn't making crazy money
jason momoa was overthrown
how dare you yeah dude what was he
doing his first season he was the he was
the guy who [ __ ] the
homegirl remember that's right that's
right he was his own dothraki yeah he
told them
yeah he was living out of a van yeah he
was like i wasn't making any money like
he was like i'd walk in a store and get
bombarded but what people don't realize
i
like i was broke like he barely got paid
for that yeah
interesting even this man has 12
schmillies that's not bad
that's a lost money yeah but loss is
where he got paid that's what he
told me everyone on the contracts
because they knew it was gonna be
[ __ ] big
and they knew they're gonna be stars a
they couldn't do anything else
and they they were like contracted for
seven movies whether they made or not
they're like you're getting this much
these shows are gonna be big wither
without you got it so like if you don't
take this deal we will literally give it
to the next guy there's a million short
white guys
in right back in hollywood right [ __ ]
interesting
they ain't paying pennies like [ __ ]
nike or something right right right
right
yeah i know all right all right fine so
[ __ ] you i don't know maybe
maybe maybe morgan freeze i'm gonna try
to do movies yeah
yeah i don't know dude or we just blow
this thing up
there's slow podcasts up dude that's the
thing you own it all man
should i kill theo and just be the
co-host here what are the fans sick of
that should we
king or sting i want to do a king in the
sting do wit you king of the sting me
killing theo and being the new host
king or stinger i'm sure we if we could
see the votes you'd
stew theo would be on and go king it
kicked it
could you imagine theo kingdom oh he
probably would
all right kids i'm in naples this
weekend thursday friday saturday comedy
off the hook naples florida with the
with my crew and then next week austin
vulcan gas company theater
it's me and special guests all shows are
damn near sold out so we added a show
late thursday so come get some awesome
that is next week i'll me i go to 20 20
through the 22nd to get to f-a-t-k-z.com
for me
uh christy comedy.com my stand up dates
start in july
uh it's all over to we're adding shows
uh as well on patreon.com
christy comedy and uh uh my youtube
youtube.com
christy comedy i got my podcast chrissy
chaos on tuesdays hey babe thursdays
um captain uh off the hook comedy club
that's the guy captain brian captain
brian
sent me a text yesterday dude how about
this character how about this
i get into the first time i ever did off
the hook comedy club i think the only
time i ever did it
it was the only thing you know they've
redone it i've heard the horror stories
no it wasn't real it was a nice club i
literally get
get picked up in the airport you know
like by him he get i get in the car
he's like hey nice to meet you it's
captain brian i was like hey what's up
brian he goes it's captain brian
i said we're grown men i'm not going to
call you captain brian now is he dressed
like a sailor
swear to god dude is he dressed like a
sailor he had the sail i said but does
he own a boat
i don't know i doubt it but i remember i
said i'm not going to call you captain
brian and that was
not only was i not selling tickets but
that was a point of contention because
he was like you need to call me captain
brian i was like you know i'm an
adult biological male i will not call
you captain
you're in a [ __ ] nissan pathfinder
taking me to a chili's
yes be called captain brian yeah dude if
you don't call him captain hook
my brother does but i refuse to call him
captain as well dude you gotta call him
he's gonna get furious well that's what
it's gonna be then
that's why i have a guarantee all right
man see you this weekend naples
[Music]
i got to go in and go hard in the paint
i do not think
i am in flow black rifle coffee i'm
ready to go i need a sponsor i
am a monster about to open up with this
at my concerts flow is contagious
browser outrage is thicker than girls
that
are instagram famous damn hungry like
i'm fresh off keto
seeing red like andrew santino every
song i hit like the great bambino
burning ate the queso and the quesoritos
but
everything's gonna be fine hate on me i
do not mind theo looking like the type
of dude that got a pack of matches in
his pockets at all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat him
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you